IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
A BATTLE OVER IMPEACHMENT
PLAYING OUT IN WASHINGTON D.C.
THE PRESIDENT BLASTING DEMOCRATS
FOR THEIR LATEST CONSPIRATORIAL
ATTACKS.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE WITH CHUCK
SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI TO TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE.
RIGHT BEFORE PELOSI SAID THIS.
>> IT WAS A VERY POSITIVE
MEETING OF RESPECTFUL SHARING OF
IDEAS.
WOULD YOU BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR -- TO FOLLOW THE
FACTS?
WE BELIEVE THAT NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW, INCLUDING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS ENGAGED IN A COVER-UP.
IN A COVER-UP.
>> Jessie: AFTER THAT STUNT,
TRUMP DECIDED TO WHO UP THE
MEETING BY CALLING OUT SCHUMER
AND PELOSI TO THEIR FACES AND
WALKED AWAY.
HE HEADED TO THE ROSE GARDEN
WITH A VISUAL WHERE HE LAID INTO
DEMOCRATS.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN I HEAR LAST
NIGHT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
A MEETING BEFORE THIS MEETING TO
TALK ABOUT THE I WORD.
INSTEAD OF WALKING IN HAPPILY
INTO A MEETING, I WALK IN TO
LOOK AT PEOPLE THAT HAVE JUST
SAID I WAS DOING A COVER-UP.
I DON'T DO COVER-UPS.
I TOLD SENATOR SCHUMER, SPEAKER
PELOSI, I WANT TO DO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN'T DO IT UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO GET THESE PHONY
INVESTIGATIONS OVER WITH.
>> Jessie: SCHUMER AND PELOSI
RESPONDING BY TRYING TO SPIN THE
MEETING.
>> TO WATCH WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WOULD MAKE YOUR JAW
DROP.
I WAS PREPARED TO GIVE HIM A
35-PAGE PLAN.
WE WERE INTERESTED.
WE ARE INTERESTED IN DOING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S CLEAR THE PRESIDENT ISN'T.
THIS WAS NOT A SPONTANEOUS MOVE
ON THE PRESIDENT'S PART.
IT WAS PLANNED.
>> Jessie: THE PRESIDENT WASN'T
HAVING IT.
HE FIRED BACK TWEETING, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TEARING THE
COUNTRY APART.
OF COURSE, PELOSI HAS SINCE
DOUBLED DOWN ON HER COVER-UP
COMMENT AND SAID IT COULD BE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
DANA, IT'S CLEAR TO THE COUNTRY,
THAT NANCY AND CHUCK CANNOT WORK
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
SO FAR THEY HAVE SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT, NO BORDER SECURITY,
NO INFRASTRUCTURE.
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT'S A MESS.
>> Dana: SO THE DEMOCRATS --
WHAT IS THE GOOD NEWS THAT THEY
COULD POINT TO IN JANUARY THAT
THEY HAVE DONE?
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT HAS GONE
THEIR WAY?
NOT REALLY.
OKAY?
THEY MIGHT SPIN A COUPLE THINGS.
THEY MIGHT SAY THE PRESIDENT'S
POLL NUMBERS ARE DOWN.
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT SAY I MIGHT
NOT GET A LOT DONE WITH CONGRESS
BUT THE THINGS THAT I HAVE DONE
UNDER MY CONTROL, I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO EXECUTE ON AND LOOK AT OUR
ECONOMY, LOOK AT ALL -- WE HAVE
THE LIST.
WE CAN GO THROUGH THE LIST.
THE THINK ABOUT HER, NANCY
PELOSI, IS SHE'S SUPER
STRATEGIC.
WE KNOW SHE'S VERY WISE.
SHE'S VERY GOOD AT POLITICS.
SHE DIDN'T JUST SAY COVER-UP AS
LIKE AN OFFHAND REMARK.
THIS WAS A DELIBERATE INTENTION.
SHE'S UNDER THE PRESSURE FROM --
>> Jessie: SHE'S FORCED TO SAY
THAT.
>> AND IT GETS UNDER HIS SKIN.
SHE LOVES TO GET HIM RILED UP SO
SHE CAN SAY OH, MY GOSH.
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE THE
REACTION.
IT WAS OVERWHELMING AND I HAVE
TO PRAY FOR HIM.
>> Jessie: HER CAUCUS WANTS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPEACHMENT.
>> Dana: THEY WANT IT ALL.
THAT'S TRUE.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS IDEA IS
I'M JUST PICTURING IT, THEY'RE
IN THE CABINET ROOM.
THE PRESIDENT WALKING IN, NOT
SITTING DOWN.
YEAH, THIS STUFF IS OVER.
LIKE WE'RE NOT DOING THIS.
IF YOU THINK BACK TO WHEN HIS
SUPPORTERS WOULD SAY IN A
PRIMARY ELECTION, WHAT DO YOU
LIKE ABOUT HIM?
THEY WOULD SAY HE TELLS IT LIKE
IT IS.
IT WAS A CHARADE TO THINK ONE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE WAS GOING TO
GET DONE ANYWAY.
THEY'RE SO FAR APART ANYWAY.
SO THAT WAS A CHARADE.
IT WASN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE PRESIDENT SAID LET'S STOP
PRETENDING.
YOU JUST -- YOU'RE HERE TO HELP
GET ME IMPEACHED BUT TO PRETEND
TO WORK ON THINGS.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
>> Jessie: WHY WOULD YOU
NEGOTIATE WHEN SOMEBODY HAS A
KNIFE TO YOUR THROUGHOUT?
>> Greg: THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF POLITICS CLASHING WITH
BUSINESS.
WHAT NANCY AND CHUCK DID IS PLAN
AND POLITICAL.
I WOULD BE BUSINESSED OFF, TOO.
IT'S LIKE DANA COMING "THE FIVE"
AND ANNOUNCING SHE BURNED MY
HOUSE DOWN.
YOU DON'T DO THAT WHEN YOU'RE IN
BUSINESS, NO ONE BEFORE A
MEETING WOULD ACCUSE YOU OF
BEING A CRIMINAL.
RIGHT?
IN POLITICS, THERE'S NO SUCH
LIMITATION.
THEY CALL YOU A WAR CRIMINAL AND
HAVE LUNCH WITH YOU.
WHEN THEY SAID WELL CLEARLY HE
DOESN'T WANT INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOW STUPID DO YOU THINK THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC IS?
HE WAS PISSED OFF BECAUSE OF
WHAT YOU DID.
IT HAD -- HE WANTS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HE'S BEEN DOING INFRASTRUCTURE
HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
I LOVE THAT HE BROUGHT VISUALS
THAT MEANS HE'S INCORPORATING
FOX GRAPHICS INTO HIS DISPLAY.
TRUMP'S POLL NUMBERS MIGHT BE
DOWN, BUT WHEN YOU ASK AMERICANS
WHAT KIND OF JOB HE'S DOING AND
IF THEY'RE BETTER OFF?
THEY'RE WAY HIGH.
HOW STUPID DO YOU HAVE TO BE TO
SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT?
IMPEACHMENT FAILS.
TRUMP IS A FOLK HERO.
IMPEACHMENT SUCCEEDS, HE'S A
FOLK HERO AND YOU HAVE PENCE AS
PRESIDENT AND TRUMP IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
YOU'LL HAVE TWO REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO AND
ELECT BERNIE SANDERS AFTER THIS.
YOU'LL HAVE 75 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT ARE PISSED OFF AND THEY'RE
GOING TO RE-ELECT PENCE.
THE POINT IS -- THE PENDULUM
SWINGS.
THE MORE YOU JUMP OVER, THE MORE
YOU PUSH, THE MORE THEY PUSH
BACK.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL SEE WITH
BREXIT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
IT WILL CREATE MORE FANS.
>> Jessie: JUAN?
>> I'M SO AMAZED TO LISTEN.
SEEMS LIKE TRUMP DID A BIG STUNT
WHERE HE DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO PAY
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON.
LAST TIME HE WAS ENGAGED IN A
CONVERSATION WITH DEMOCRATS
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE, HE GOT IN
TROUBLE WITH FELLOW REPUBLICANS
WHO SAID HEY, HOLD ON,
MR. PRESIDENT.
WE'RE NOT RAISING TAXES.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A GAS
TAX.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
REPEALING TAX CUTS THAT YOU PUT
IN PLACE, UNPOPULAR AS THEY MAY
BE.
GUESS WHAT?
IF YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE DEMOCRATS
SAID $2 TRILLION, YOU HAVE TO
FIND THE MONEY FROM SOMEWHERE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHERE TO GET THE
MONEY.
>> Jessie: WAIT.
JUAN.
YOU --
>> THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> Jessie: YOU THINK HE SHALL BE
DODGED THE MEETING BECAUSE YOU
THINK HE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE THE
MONEY WAS COMING FROM?
HE DOESN'T CARE WHERE THE MONEY
IS COMING FROM.
>> SOMEBODY HAS TO GOVERN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Greg: OH, COME ON.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT PREPLAINED.
WHAT WAS PREPLANNED IS HIS ROSE
GARDEN CEREMONY BEFORE THEY GOT
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jessie: JUAN, MAYBE PELOSI
MISCALCULATED.
SHE SAID SOMETHING AGGRESSIVE.
MISCALCULATED AND ACCUSED THE
PRESIDENT OF A COVER-UP AND NOW
THE MEN PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHAT A CRAZY THING HE SAID.
NOTHING WILL GET DONE.
THAT MEANS GUESS WHAT,
MR. PRESIDENT?
THE INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOT GOING
TO STOP.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THE COUNTRY IS
NOT GOING TO BE GOVERNED --
>> Jessie: WE HAD TWO YEARS OF
INVESTIGATIONS, JUAN.
>> BILL CLINTON WAS BEING
IMPEACH AND HE WORKED ON THE S
CHIP BUILD IN TERMS OF HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE --
>> Dana: AND HIS APPROVAL
NUMBERS WENT UP.
>> AND THIS GUY SAID HE'S NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING.
>> Emily: THE DEMOCRATS ARE SO
TRANSPARENT THAT THEY'RE WILLING
TO SABOTAGE THEIR OWN PURPORTED
INTERESTS OR THE INTERESTS OF
THEIR CONSTITUENTS RATHER THAN
GIVE TRUMP AND INCH.
NOT EVEN A VICTORY.
AN INCH.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS IT WAS SO
OBVIOUS THAT YES, THIS IS A
CHARADE.
YES, THIS WAS PLANNED.
YES, IT WAS STRATEGY.
IT WAS PELOSI TOSSING A LIT
MATCH ON TO THE BUNDLE OF CINDER
THAT IS TRUMP WHEN SHE SAYS
THERE'S A COVER-UP AND SHE HAS
THOSE BUZZ WORDS.
OF COURSE HE'S GOING TO FREAK
OUT.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BIPARTISAN.
THE MONEY IS ABSOLUTELY THERE
WHEN THERE'S PROJECTED $3
TRILLION IN AUDITS UNCOVERED IN
THE GOVERNMENT, IN TERMS OF LIKE
FLASHING SPENDING.
THE MONEY IS ABSOLUTELY THERE.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE IS THAT THESE GUYS ARE
PUTTING THE DEAL BEFORE
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF WHAT IT
REPRESENTS.
THE SCHUMER AND PELOSI WERE
INTERESTED IN INFRASTRUCTURE,
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE PULLED THIS
STUNT.
SCHUMER, IT WAS LIKE THE NICENE
CREED.
WE BELIEVE IN THIS AND WE
BELIEVE IN THIS.
IT'S A FARCE FROM TOP TO BOTTOM.
>> YOU THINK THERE'S MONEY
SITTING THERE.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT --
>> Emily: YES.
>> Jessie: IT'S NOT ABOUT MONEY.
THEY'RE ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT
OF COVERING UP A CRIME THAT
NEVER HAPPENED.
>> WASHINGTON INTERFERENCE NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> Jessie: I LOVE HOW HE SHIFTED
THAT.
HE SAID RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
HE DIDN'T SAY COLLUSION.
I LOVE THE USE OF THE PHRASE
COVER-UP ON THE SAME DAY THE